-My first guest tonight is one
of the biggest movie stars
on the planet!
he produced and stars in
the new movie, "Jungle Cruise,"
Which is in theaters and on
Disney+, with premiere access
July 30th, here is
Dwayne Johnson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Hey!
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you feel?
-Thank you.
-Can you feel the love?
-I can feel the love
from that audience,
Thank you guys so much,
I love you back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're so happy to see you.
Thank you for
coming back, buddy.
We have a lot to talk about.
I want to talk about, first,
you just finished filming
"Black Atom" and here's some
photo of you,
in the middle of filming,
gosh you are ripped
in this thing.
Like, that is unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-Now, no one trains harder
than you.
No one trains harder
I follow you on Instagram,
I see all these things
that you do, I go,
"Oh, my gosh."
And I remember that you've been
tyrannizing for this
for two years, but you also do,
like, cheat meals
every now and then,
when you're not training.
What was your cheat meal for
this workout?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you know, I had been
training and preparing for
"Black Atom" for a few years now
because I felt like it was,
you get one shot at creating,
hopefully creating something
that's definitive in the world
of superheroes
and comic book lore
and mythology.
So, I really put in the work on
this one, Jimmy.
And, um, and as far as for the
cheat meals, I --
after that because that,
actually what you're seeing,
was actually my very last day of
shooting "Black Atom"
So we wrapped
probably around midnight,
and I would say by 1:30 a.m.,
I was face first in the biggest
pile of pancakes
you could imagine.
[ Applause ]
-I know you love your pancakes.
You also love your French toast,
I see every now and then.
You're like French toast and,
was it peanut butter?
What do you put on there?
-Oh, dude, let me tell you,
now that you asked.
I do big thick
brioche French toast.
I call it "Rock toast."
Four inches thick.
Uh, we do peanut butter,
I'll do some butter,
I'll do some, uh,
teremana-infused syrup,
I'll do coconut chips,
whipped cream,
and I bring new meaning to the
word "gluttony."
[ Laughter ]
-How's the family, by the way?
I know you just posted about
your daughter,
your daughter's love --
she's probably three now, maybe?
-Yes, Tia.
-Your daughter's love for
Aquaman -- she loves Aquaman.
And there's a funny video of
you, because I know Jason Momoa
he was on our show and he sent a
nice video to wish her
happy birthday,
and, but here's a video
to show you how much she love
Aquaman.
Take a look at Tia
and Dwayne.
-Look what Aquaman did
to that man.
-I saw what Aquaman just did.
Who's cooler? Daddy?
-Aquaman.
-Aquaman?
[ Audience moans ]
[ Dwayne and Jimmy laugh ]
-Good timing. Good timing.
It was great timing on her part
she didn't even let you say
Aqua-- like "Who's cooler,
Daddy?" "Aquaman."
She didn't even let you finish.
-Dude, she, she jumped
right on that, which is great
for the ego,
but I gotta say that, you know,
in the world of celebrities,
you know, you never know
who's nice and who's kind
until you meet them or, or
really until, you know,
little children are involved.
And I've known Jason for a very
long time now.
I'm very proud of his career
and all the things
that's he's been doing.
So, I gotta tell you, I called
up Jason, I said,
"Man, I know you're busy,
you're on set,
but my daughter, specifically my
three-year-old daughter,
she adores you, we watch
'Aquaman' all the time.
She thinks you're way cooler
than Daddy.
And it's her birthday
coming up, man."
And he sent the most beautiful
birthday video to Tia,
as well as to Jazzy.
Aquaman invited them to Hawaii
where we're gonna swim
in the ocean together and we're
gonna go rock climbing.
He made all these promises that
make me look bad, Jimmy.
-Yeah, of course.
Exactly.
You know what, I want to ask,
more importantly,
for me, you know my relationship
with your mom.
How is your mom doing? Because
last time she was on the show,
I don't know if you guys saw
this but...
-[ Laughs ]
-...she happened to be around.
I was talking about your mom and
playing ukulele.
And you're like, "She's actually
here, if you want to see her."
She came in, totally hijacked
the interview
and played beautiful
ukulele music.
And how is she doing? Did fame
go to her head? Is she, uh?
-I don't know. I can't talk to
her, she's a diva now.
-[ Laughs ]
-I have to go through her
assistant's assistant assistant
to talk to my mom.
But it was crazy,
I remember that.
Well, first of all,
she loves you.
She adores you and she thinks
you're the greatest thing
walking God's green earth,
Jimmy.
So, when she pulled out that
ukulele I --
both you and I had no idea where
she was gonna go.
-So scared.
-And she starts singing
♪ We love you, Jimmy ♪
-Yes!
-♪ Oh, yes, it's true ♪
I was like, wait, mom, what?
-[ Laughs ] It was, those
moments you can't plan.
Please give her my love,
please, buddy.
-I will.
-I want to talk about teremana.
Your tequila. This is --
it's the fastest-growing
spirits brand to date.
The fastest-growing spirits
of any, to date.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not too shabby, buddy.
-Yes, thank you very much.
-There's a thing called
the Mana Mobile and if it
doesn't stop by my house
where can I see it?
Where can I see this thing
and what is this?
-Dude that -- so the Mana Mobile
serves tacos,
it serves special recipes,
it serves teremana cocktails,
it serves french toast.
And that Mana Mobile is going
coast to coast.
Multiple Mana Mobiles are going
And we wanted to bring
the mana to the people.
So that Mana Mobile will be
going to fire stations,
military bases,
college campuses, communities,
food festivals, you name it, the
Mana Mobile is coming to you.
-Yeah, look out
for the Mana Mobile.